you know it's tough to follow up the
movie of the year with anything the next
week but they're gonna try salt that is
a short title or sweet seeing the
trailers to salt for a while nan we had
the wonder if it was gonna be like Tom
Clancy or useful is born or it's about
the beginning of salt in the first scene
you're watching it you think yourself
this is gonna be way cooler than I
thought it was gonna be this is awesome
then every scene after that just gets
more and more cartoony no but I did like
about salt was when the Russian guy
points the finger says yeah you Evelyn
salt you're a spy than the chase is on
you don't really know what side she's on
I mean is she good is she bad I mean you
think and you theorize but you just
don't know I thought I knew before I
went into the movie and I kind of didn't
know but I didn't really know you
confused yet
I like watching movie like this not
knowing if the person was like Friend or
Foe not knowing if you're supposed to be
rooting for them trying to figure out
the twist before they reveal him to you
kind of the point of a movie like Desmet
let's be serious there were a couple of
twists in this movie that I didn't
really see coming but they weren't big
enough for me to be like that is so big
that that's just awesomely memorable
this is just really not the cast was
pretty good I mean Angelina Jolie was
good Liev Schreiber was good Sabretooth
is always good except in x-men origins
because that whole movie was horrible
the action was really cool in some
scenes and other scenes I'll be honest
was just downright like there's
a scene where she's jumping down a shaft
and she's clearly on cables cuz she's
floating across the shaft and it's
noticeably on a blue screen yeah that'll
kill it for you and there's another
scene where she's sliding down two beams
with her hands on the beams sliding down
using her palms what women who work used
to be in Russian spies like impervious
to friction burns no that's
there were definitely a couple of plot
holes in the movie things that just
didn't make sense
but do fall under the spoiler territory
so I can't really talk about him that
much but they're there Oh trust me
they're there one of which has to do
with the ending I'm not buying the
ending at all
one thing was against character and the
other was just illogical just when it
comes to the end just don't go around
your elbow to get to your ass
metaphorically speaking and actually in
the end salt is like the lovechild of no
way out in Mission Impossible 2 it just
has more potential than reality it could
have been really really cool if it was
like a realistic espionage movie but
instead big popcorn movie that was made
for the sake of making another Bourne
trilogy it has his cool moments and his
cheesy moments all admit it was fun and
it was better than I thought it would be
but I guarantee you I'll go to bed when
I wake up in the morning I'll forget
like 63 percent of this movie it's just
one of those movies you'll walk out
until your friends I had a lot of fun so
you'd see it again dude but again no
definitely not so if you like mission
impossible - or the saying honestly
you'll probably like salt but if you're
looking for the next Patriot Games or 24
probably not going to find it here but
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more because I am professional
and objective and all that
[Music]